because we're living in the most radical
culture we've ever seen where
even dr seuss
is not safe from being canceled
six books by dr seuss will no longer be
published
those those books are and to think that
i saw it on mulberry street actually
these are books that i haven't really
read of dr seuss's they're kind of
smaller books though i love mulberry
street i kind of wish i had that book
if i ran the zoo mcelligot's pool
on beyond zebra scrambled eggs super
and the cat's quizzer these dr seuss
books probably the most beloved
children's author
ever in the history of the united states
they're banned because
they have insensitive and politically
correct depictions of
cats or something i don't i don't know i
haven't haven't read them
universal islands of adventure theme
park which is located in florida
is now looking rid of uh getting rid of
the dr
seuss themed area of the park in light
of the new new cancellation of certain
dr seuss books
i tried to buy these dr seuss books for
my cute little baby
sweet little newborn june wanted to make
sure that he had access to dr seuss
when he was a kid you can't find them if
you if you go on amazon and other places
these books the the remaining supply are
selling for like two thousand dollars
right now because they know they're not
going to be produced anymore
the left is thrilled about this
washington post
defending the cancellation of dr seuss
this is
philip bump writing for the washington
post i don't know who philip bump
is now they don't include a biography of
him the headline if curtailing racist
imagery
in dr seuss is cancelled culture what
exactly
is your culture it's a bunch of
nonsense but the lines that matter no
one is canceling dr seuss a phrase by
now so detached from reality that it
doesn't even make any sense
the author himself is dead for one thing
which is about as cancelled as a person
can get
uh not true if you believe in heaven you
damned heretic
but nevertheless i digress the vast vast
majority of his books
the ones without racist images or
references will still be sold the ones
without racist
imagery you sure about that isn't
i'll pause there by the way that the
term racist has been expanded
in recent years expanded to mean
absolutely nothing at all
the charge that he makes about the
phrase canceled culture do you really
think
that any of our past is safe from
cancellation
i don't i think everything is going to
be called racist
or if they finally deprive the word
racist of all meaning which i think
effectively they already have
they'll just come up with a new term you
already see they post the supremacist
nationalist now is a bad term they're
just gonna cancel every do you really if
you can cancel dr seuss
do you really think they're gonna stop
with a few books of dr seuss
but this fellow at the washington post
goes on
if dr seuss's profile wanes a bit as a
result of the attention being paid to
his drawings the only form of
cancelling at play here to whom is harm
being done
can't be to dr seuss because he's
already dead the harm is being done of
course
to our culture but
this guy goes on seuss's caricatures are
hurtful anachronisms
anachronisms right so he's what he's
saying is it's not that they're wrong
and evil he's saying they're just
outdated he's this guy
is taking a progressive view of history
so he's actually kind of already giving
up the game he's saying they're
anachronisms
meaning things from the past are bad and
you got to get rid of them
so he's undercutting his own argument
that other things from the past will be
fine and no they're they're
anachronistic
they're from the past the past is bad
it's a progressive view of history
whereby we have to kill
our forebears kill the culture that
we've inherited killed this great gift
that we've been given down through the
ages
to move into the future which will
liberate us what's more until a few
weeks ago my son didn't know this book
existed
so where's the harm in his not seeing
its images why would anyone think it is
less problematic for a kid to be exposed
to racist caricatures of
african or at a different point in this
book asian
people than for him not to be
this isn't some toxic cancel culture if
it were what would you say
what would that say about the culture
that you're defending
so he's saying look it's not cancelled
culture he's he's
undercutting his argument immediately he
says this isn't cancelled culture
but we're going to cancel all that bad
old culture and what are you going to
defend it what are you a racist or
something
right this this isn't cancelled culture
but if it were
are you a racist you're not going to
defend it are you
there is no limiting principle here this
is another
aspect of our culture and political
correctness specifically that trump got
100 right and everybody made fun of him
at the time you remember when
when he was defending robert e lee
statues there's a big left-wing hubbub
to take down robert e lee
who is one of the noblest men
to ever fight for a bad cause right
robert e lee
the idea that robert e lee was some kind
of vicious man
is preposterous it's anti-historical
and the idea that we need to erase half
of our country or more than half of our
country
probably i don't think the left just
wants to erase the south i think they
want to
erase the entire traditional american
nation
it's crazy so he said okay you're you're
going after robert e lee now and some
people aren't going to defend him
because he fought for the mean old
southerners
you really think they're going to stop
with robert e lee no i think they're
going to go after
lincoln they're going to go after
jefferson they're going to go after
washington and people laughed at him and
they mocked him at the time and then
what happened within
a year or two left-wing
agitators started pulling down statues
of jefferson
and washington and lincoln renaming
schools
erasing our culture if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
you